well as many of you know every two or
three months we have a last minute
cancellation or a no-show or a problem
with a guest and it's unfortunate but it
is impossible to prevent 100 when that
happens I say let's hear from a few
people in the audience so let's do that
now of course we take calls via Discord
at davidpackman.com
Discord let's start with Mitchell from
Ohio Mitchell what's on your mind today
what can I do for you
hi David I've been thinking a lot
recently about how most people on
opposite sides of the political Spectrum
have more in common with each other than
they will ever have with people who have
a vast amount of influence and Power in
this country true and I just can't seem
to wrap my head around how we get people
to understand that their interests are
more aligned than they think I don't
know the answer to that either and you
know what the first time that this was
like very
um evident to me was that in a movement
I covered closely it was the 2010 the
growth of the Tea Party Movement and
Jonathan height has written a lot about
this where a lot of it has to do with
you're not thinking in terms of what is
actually best for me and the vast
majority of people including people who
supposedly are on the opposite political
side you're thinking in terms of my team
you're thinking in terms of the people
who I sort of take direction from what
are they telling me to do what are they
saying is best and I I genuinely don't
know a lot of this has very deep
psychology
um written into it as Jonathan height
has written about and I don't because
you're absolutely right on so many
issues particularly economic issues even
if we put aside social issue differences
the vast majority of Americans actually
have the same interests and would
benefit from the same policies and yet
they are split between two political
parties
I'd I'd have to agree with you I and if
you ask anyone from either party or
either side of the aisle I feel like
most people just want to be able to put
in an honest day's work for an honest
day's wage come home to their family and
do it again the next day and put a
little money aside but I do you think
that there's truth to that there's an
artificial culture War being started by
you know people like Rhonda santis to
try and stop people from seeing the
economic uh issues that they actually
have in common that's one way to put it
I the way and I don't think you're wrong
the way I've said it is a little
different which is the country keeps
moving left on policy particularly
Economic Policy so what the right has
done is abandon policy particularly
economic policy and do the culture War
so I don't know that it's overtly to
prevent people from realizing that's an
interesting perspective but I think it's
basically if it was just about policy
Republic applicants would have a even
tougher time winning elections so they
make it about something else instead but
it's basically the same thing you're
saying
yeah it's all it's all very interesting
I appreciate your perspective thank you
for taking my call all right Mitchell
from Ohio very important and well said I
appreciate that